hello internets traveler my name is
Charlie and some of you might remember
back in 2008 I wrote a song called blink
I wrote this as part of my band
chameleon circuit who played songs about
Doctor Who please don't judge us it's a
good show stop judging us but that
girlfriend was so 2008 it's been a long
time coming but me and the band have
finally put together a real-life CD of
music that exists in the world like a
real thing
we're like a real band that makes real
CDs now the physical CD thing complete
with booklets with lyrics in and stuff
is available from dftba.com but if you
don't like you know old-school CDs you
can also get the mp3 downloads on iTunes
and on Amazon mp3 I'm very proud of this
and I think it's very good but obviously
you're not gonna listen to me because
I'm trying to sell it to you anybody who
tries to sell you things is obviously
lying all the time so what I've decided
to do is make a collaboration video with
lots of people who have already bought
the CD and enjoyed it thankfully and
they're gonna tell you why they like the
CD and dance around to the music so here
is that go oh my god the CD has changed
my life have you ever wondered what also
in your life thought a compact disc this
is it baby
before chameleon circuit I was sad and
lonely and now I have a super hot
boyfriend
hey maybe before chameleon circuit I
didn't know what to do with my life and
now it has purpose yam is so amazing
isn't that what's haunting describing
before chameleon circuit I was dirt poor
and now I have a million dollars it's
much better than Miley Cyrus let's put
it that way
commune circuit is you never want to
stop the time lord rahl
it's been such a long time since I met
you back on Skaro
and I'm pretty sure that you know God
God much has changed since then
it doesn't matter how hard you try to
remove me I think you will agree that if
one of us dies then the other will - I
locked in war with you
by
what keeps Richard
ship levy planet
before chameleon circuit I was
completely lame and I've got some sweet
dance moves
wait a second what am i doing in my own
collab video that's right everybody
apparently I don't have enough friends
to make an entire collab video so I
could only make half the collab video I
can understand if you only you know half
satisfied with that cloud video but
don't blame me blame my friends that
don't exist if you enjoyed that thing
that I made then you can like I said get
the CD the physical CD singing from
dftba.com
and you can get it on iTunes and Amazon
mp3 I do want to point out I realize I'm
selling you something today but that
does not mean please don't think that
that means I'm a sellout this is
something that has taken me a long time
to make and I put a lot of effort into
this and I'm very very proud of it I'm
not here to sell out you don't have to
buy this you know I don't I don't mind
if you if you're not interested but I'm
really passionate about this and I
really want to share it with you so if
you're interested you could buy it if
you're not interested don't don't make
it seem like I'm forcing you to buying
something I hope you understand that I
am honestly I was scared to make this
video because I am afraid of being
branded a sellout I've always been
afraid of that and honestly I get a lot
of emails from people telling me to you
know sell things in my videos we'll do
product placement and that kind of stuff
and I've been offered good money to do
that but I am I'm not interested because
these videos aren't worth it for me
unless I'm honest with you say that's
that I will see you sometime in 2010
because apparently that's how often I
make my videos nowadays goodbye